Chris Haynes for the mothership he's
covering the warrior side during the NBA
Finals but two former Cavs beat reporter
for the Cleveland Plain Dealer Chris
good to have you back on how are you
door five six to 220 I'm getting heavier
what's the biggest difference in
covering these two teams since you've
done both how can I put this let's see
um I will say the Warriors culture you
have a lot more especially you know
media and relationships right there they
they offer us like a media friendly
culture where players are available the
players actually have a good
relationship with the media you're able
to be able to request a lot of
one-on-ones and and uh Kevin Durant who
has been the tourist you know for not
really divulging much or speaking
speaking with the media especially in
101 group setting when was OKC that has
change will go to state Cleveland there
a little bit more stricter they they
allowed it they try to keep the media
pretty much out of arms distance with
the players of the a if you kind of
offer that type of dynamic the players
kind of resent some of the media folks
so I would say that's that's probably
some of the different dynamics as far as
how I do my job working with both teams
but does it come down to LeBron is
running the media availability and is
there somebody is Steph Curry running
the media availability with Golden State
unofficially unofficially outlook LeBron
can do what he want to do you know he's
been you know obviously over the last
couple of days where he's boycotted
going to the podium you know obviously
we were told that he's getting tired of
waiting to go to the podium
you know usually he's probably one of
the last players who are assigned to the
podium after the coaches speak some of
the other players never change speed so
he's been doing this for you know seven
straight years going
finals and it kind of lingered into the
Eastern Conference Finals for him as
well but yeah definitely LeBron you know
he has he can exhort his power for say
and but yeah there's there's none of
that going on with the Warriors Jeff Van
Gundy said that curry and Durant could
be the best duo ever do you think that's
just in the moment watching the Warriors
be great in Game two and then you throw
something out or do you think there's
real validity in something like that no
I think it's in the moment right now I
think um you know Paul Pierce you know
said that right now KB is the best
player I you know Katie's playing well
you know he's definitely on
she's definitely producing at a higher
level up you know compared to LeBron but
you know LeBron is the best player the
best duo you know you still got look at
magic and Kareem and Jordan and Pippen I
mean go to state you know what this view
hasn't won the championship yet I think
you've probably got to win multiple
championships to be you'd be considered
amongst the you know greatest duel of
all time and you know up until the
finals you know Stefan curry really
hasn't had a great final showing you
know there so I think it's a little
premature but we're also looking at this
Golden State team and I mentioned first
hour if they sweep we'll look at them
differently than if they win in six
games if they sweep they don't lose a
game I think historically we're going to
look at them and say maybe that's the
best season that somebody's ever had as
opposed to if they lose two games to the
Cavaliers is that thick how history is
going to look at this game is that fair
to them
no I spare you know art will be one of
the best seasons a team has ever had
even upstaging the 73 in 73 wins from
last year but but still like we are
talking about the greatest duo I just
don't know if even sweeping the playoffs
is going to put them in that class what
we know one chefs I mean it would depend
on what they do from you know here on
now say they sweep win the championship
and then the next couple of years you
know maybe they don't perform as well or
maybe my I don't see this happening
maybe they don't get to the India finals
again you know so I think right now they
they are still trying to carve their
name and to the likes of those other
duels that I've mentioned right now
but obviously this year man what they're
doing how they're playing that they can
sustain this I definitely think you got
to put them in the talks as being you
know having our Lee the great great one
of the greatest teams in NBA history
he's Chris Haines from the mothership
he's covering the Warriors during the
NBA Finals formerly a Cavs beat writer
for the Cleveland Plain Dealer
what do you make of Mike wise from the
mothership saying that you could smell
marijuana in the Cavs locker room after
Game two
you know what I was in there a little
bit I smelled ice know the twins of it I
would say that I don't know where it
came from I don't know who you know I
don't think complicated is a Cavalier
players are blazing if they do blaze I
don't think they're blazing that quickly
after a game to loss but you know there
was definitely I mean it is California
you know it is the Bay Area yeah but
it's the NBA Finals and you're in a
locker room there Chris right that's
what here like who would be smoking in
the locker room in the first place I
never a velocity or something hangers-on
yeah well I would say I would say that
the other you do have a lot of you know
players in there you know and they're
their buddies in there but I would if I
had to guess who was the culprit you
know look yeah you've been in the NBA
Finals there's a lot of media moreso
media and it's not even the media that
traditionally this media that's coming
in they're trying to get pictures trying
to uh you know get a selfie you know
you're going to blame this on the media
and like somebody sparking up from the
media I'm saying that this is what I'm
saying then I'm saying out this time of
year you get a lot of media so-called
media around that you don't see during
the regular season that come from
anywhere the NBA allows for some reason
allows more media during the finals or
any other type of you know around and I
would say a lot of my aren't doing a job
they're just taking
[ __ ] want to be seen and they
probably have some you know probably
engage in a lot of extracurricular
activities and I think probably some of
that residue of what they were doing
prior to hiring rooms kind of lingered
incident residue what I'm saying that's
what I'm sticking with but what you're
saying though Chris is Doris Burke was
not sparking up in the locker room right
is that it wasn't doors Berg right or PJ
Carlesimo I'll be with Doris and PJ the
first second and third rounds I've been
around them I've never had that little
chat
all right I'm just talking with I just
wanted it okay but you're a good
reporter who yeah you're good reporter
and I me person I do not engage very
nice but it wasn't me as well all right
uh finish the sentence if the Cavs get
swept like if the Cavs get swept Kevin
Love will be traded over to summer I
thought he was going to be dealt if they
lost last year I thought he was going to
be the scapegoat and I agree with you
but I don't know what you get if you
trade kept the Kevin Love what are you
hoping to get in return if you try what
yeah it's unfortunately this cable he's
escaped go every year it's been like
that ever since he's been there um
right or wrong but I think what in
straighten Kevin Love look there's
obviously you know me and my son
reporter you know back in January that
the Knicks were looking to trade
Carmelo for Kevin Love I I don't know
necessarily what you get back as far as
are you improving but I think the fact
is that they know who they are and what
they are whichever love and if go to
state if they keep this team together
they're going to continue to be there
for the next couple of years and I know
LeBron I covered the guy he's not going
to be willing to just be satisfied with
making the finals that's not going to be
enough if he feels like you know this
team is not ready and equipped to defeat
of the Golden State Warriors you have to
hear he wants he's going to want to see
some change and that day Kevin Love is
the easiest piece that you could move
bring it a likes like Carmelo look I
don't know if they were to get better
but with Carlo 1d Carmelo Chris no but
listen listen DP with Carmelo or anybody
else it's the unknown after this yeah no
mate
maybe we're better you're maybe we can
tell ever with Kevin Love they know what
they are in who they are and how far
they can go can that's trash can they
trade Kevin Love for Andrew Wiggins did
[Laughter]
they did they did they hold on to the
receipt with that trade they're okay if
they're what our policy yes hey Chris
keep stirring it up always great to talk
to you thank you for joining us
oh thanks DPX have a nice cursings ESPN
NBA reporter the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience